(piano music)
- I sort of fell in love with the country,
with the people, with the
idea of the revival of
a Jewish community in
the country of Ukraine.
And I decided that this
is where I wanna be.
I wanna stay here and open a bakery.
My name is Aaron Levitz,
I'm a baker from New York
living in Uzhhorod, Ukraine.
(piano music)
I met my wife when I was in
culinary school in New York
and she's from Ukraine so we
decided to move to Ukraine.
I can't really sit in New York,
where everything is Jewishly comfortable
when I know that in Ukraine,
things are difficult.
I feel that I have a larger connection
with the Jews of Ukraine.
Jewish life in Uzhhorod before the war
compared to today is a huge contrast.
Before the war you had many
synagogues, many rabbis.
The Nazis came and they shipped
everyone out to Auschwitz
and now there's no real community.
(chime music)
My part now in the Jewish community
is to make an attempt at a Jewish revival
and so we're starting with food.
It's not really practical to make
a kosher bakery in Ukraine
or in Uzhhorod just for Jews,
you're not really gonna make any money
cause there's not enough Jews,
so that's why I wanna introduce new ideas,
new American pastries, Jewish pasteries
that are just not common here, so,
try to get the interest of people.
I would say that I'm introducing some
Jewish and American foods
that are non-judgmental.
Some people are scared
to go to a synagogue
or scared to go to a
prayer service or something
but they'll come into a bakery
and have something tasty to eat.